mais d'abord c'est l'un des plus grands
élevages de canards colverts en france
250 mille oiseaux certains destinés à la
chasse sont produits chaque année dans
cette exploitation de serre et la ronde
un élevage intensif épinglé dans une
vidéo diffusée aujourd'hui par un
militant écologiste
on y voit des carcasses de canard à
l'air libre le propriétaire se défend
voyez ce reportage d'hélène chapelet
avec rémy carton dans cette nouvelle
vidéo mise en ligne en début de journée
sur le site de pierre rigaud militants
animalistes on découvre les conditions
de vie des canards colverts élevé à
céret la ronde
au delà des images habituelles de
l'élevage en captivité est ce qui peut
aussi choqué ce sont ces cadavres de
canetons qui s'entassent à l'extérieur
de l'exploitation beaucoup de cân tho
qui meurt dans ces élevages et ses
cadavres là seront pas tous jetés dans
la poubelle d'équarrissage prévu à cet
effet les cadavres sont jetés dehors sur
un tas de fumier hawk à l'air libre ce
qui me semble pas tellement
correspondent aux à ce qu'on peut
attendre en termes de respect des
consignes sanitaires pour la diffusion
des maladies pour vérifier la véracité
de ces images nous nous rendons donc sur
place dans un champ nous retrouvons
rapidement là où les images des cadavres
de canetons ont été filmés nous sommes
ici environ 200 mètres de l'exploitation
avicole mis en cause derrière moi ce qui
semble être un tas de fumier sauf que
quand on approche
l'odeur est réellement insupportable
dans ce tas de fumier nous avons
retrouvé des quantités 2 mais aussi des
canards en décomposition alors au delà
de la polémique des images ce qui est
sûr c'est qu'il y ait ici un manquement
grave aux règles sanitaires obligatoires
car tout animal mort doit être envoyées
à l'équarrissage
direction ensuite l'exploitation avicole
son gérant nous explique qu'il suit à la
lettre les recommandations sanitaires en
congelant les cadavres des canetons
il nous fournit une explication pour la
présence des coquilles d'oeufs dans son
fumier mais pas des cadavres le meilleur
moyen de fertiliser aujourd'hui plutôt
que d'acheter des engrais chimiques
c'était de de revaloriser seco qui donc
ce calcaire à travers les épandages donc
oui on peut retrouver des coquilles
ide dans le tas de fumier les mccann a
mais pas de canards morts dans le temps
d'expliquer la vidéo alors la vidéo à
part je vous explique
à part avoir récupéré des cadavres dans
le bac de carrie sage et les avoir
emmenés de l'autre côté jeu
je sais pas selon lui c'est donc le
militant qui aurait placé ces cadavres
dans son tas de fumier
ils nous annoncent vouloir porter
plainte pour avoir constaté son
intrusion dans une installation classée
la préfecture quant à elle va diligenter
une nouvelle inspection des lieux dans
les prochains jours